wasallam
if the people of Ash-Sham
become corrupted,
then there is no good in you all.
So, let's
really examine this narration for a
moment.
First of all, how many of us have
actually heard of this narration before?
Have we heard it before? Yeah?
Maybe a couple.
What is Ash-Sham that he's speaking
about? So, Ash-Sham, as identified by
the scholars of Islam, is currently
divided into four general countries.
If you take the
really the epitome of what is called
currently the Middle East,
you take Lebanon, Syria, Palestine,
and Jordan.
These
four countries, they almost form a
crescent. These four countries, they are
referred to in the time of the Prophet
sallallahu alayhi wasallam as Ash-Sham.
That is the land of Ash-Sham.
The epitome of Ash-Sham
is
Syria, Damascus.
Palestine is mentioned in the Quran.
Things occurred in Jordan.
Jordan was referred to as al-Urdun in
the time of the Prophet sallallahu
alayhi wasallam.
Syria is the epitome of Ash-Sham, and
these surrounding countries.
So, Syria, namely the capital of Syria,
which is Damascus,
that is the epitome of Ash-Sham.
And then we have Palestine, which shares
borders, and Lebanon, and also Jordan.
These four countries make up Ash-Sham.
Now, the Prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam said this
before
Ash-Sham
was a Muslim country, was a Muslim land.
They weren't even Muslim yet in Ash-Sham
when he made this statement.
They were still
mainly ruled and governed by the Romans
at the time.
And the Roman Empire was extremely
Christian.
And during that time,
in Palestine, in Syria, in these areas,
it was ruled by Caesar, which is a title
for the Romans that was the general
leader of the area of Ash-Sham. It was
under his governance in the time of the
Prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam.
However, he is in the Arab Peninsula
before the people of Ash-Sham generally
accepted Islam.
And he tells his companions, radiyallahu
anhum,
he says,
"If the people of Ash-Sham, and if
Ash-Sham becomes corrupted,
then there is no good in all of you."
Now, when he says in all of you, who is
he speaking about?
The Muslimin in general, right? All of
the Muslimin.
Why is he saying this? Well, Ash-Sham
would later prove to be one of the most
rich and vibrant
ambassadors of Islam.
Of course, the capital, the most
you know, core and heart of Islam with
respect to its holy sites
is Mecca, is Medina, and also al-Aqsa,
which is in Ash-Sham.
But Ash-Sham
would later prove to be a stronghold of
Islam for over a thousand years.
Over 1,000 years, Ash-Sham acted as our
Constantinople.
That's what Ash-Sham was.
It was the stronghold of Islam. It was
where all the scholars were. It was
where all the expansion of the Muslim
Empire was. It was absolutely critical
to Islam, and it continues to be
critical to Islam.
However,
our Prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam
tells us that Constantinople
would fall one day.
Right? He prophesied that Constantinople
would fall, that it would be
taken, and it would be
you know, eventually governed by the
Muslimin. And this happened in the time
of Muhammad al-Fatih from the Ottoman
Empire.
But when Constantinople
fell, when it was conquered,
what did that mean for Christianity at
large?
It was like
cutting the head off of Christianity.
It It was a sign that Christianity
had finally been defeated to its core,
and it was no longer the ruling and
governing
strength in the world.
That then moved and shifted to the
Muslimin.
Ash-Sham for the Muslimin
is the heart for the rest of the
body.
The doctors among us will tell us when
the heart is
clinically not beating anymore, what
does that mean? What do we call this
person now? I mean, we don't need the
doctor for that. When someone's heart is
no longer beating, when we want to check
on someone's life or the lack thereof,
what do we look for? We look for the
heart. Is there a pulse?
If there is no pulse,
we judge that this person is no longer
alive. This person is dead.
And our Prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam
basically tells us in this narration
that Ash-Sham is our pulse as the
Muslimin.
And once Ash-Sham becomes corrupted,
notice he didn't say Ash-Sham would be
conquered. He didn't say that it would
no longer be for the Muslimin. No.
Ash-Sham will be
for the Muslimin even if al-Aqsa is
momentarily
even if the al-Aqsa is momentarily
torn down, which some narrations do
indicate that that would happen.
But it would be rebuilt, and it will
always be for the Muslimin.
And in Ash-Sham, when the revival of
Islam will come, where does Isa ibn
Maryam descend?
He descends in Damascus.
He descends in Damascus. Where? In the
heart of Ash-Sham.
Our Prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam
tells the companions hundreds of years
before
this would act as the pulse of the
Muslimin and Islam. And Ash-Sham was
really not hundreds of years, but
decades. It was taken into the empire of
the Muslimin and made its pulse during
the
governance of Umar ibn al-Khattab,
during the Khilafah of Umar ibn
al-Khattab, radiyallahu anhu.
And he had the major companions posted
in Ash-Sham, Amr ibn al-As and his
son, Abdullah ibn Amr ibn al-As, and
Muadh ibn Jabal. All of them in
Damascus, in Palestine, in Syria. All of
them
in the land of Ash-Sham. And that is
when that heart started to beat.
And then our Prophet tells us
that when that heart
becomes sick,
when that pulse is no longer regular,
when it is erratic,
the rest of the body
is now
ailing. The rest of the body is sick.
The rest of the body is on the brink of
death. That's what Ash-Sham means.
And so, our Prophet tells us in this
narration,
he says, "If the people of Ash-Sham
become corrupted,
then there is no good in the rest of
you."
No good?
There
is no good at all. Are there not people
[Arabic recitation]
there not people that still pray and
fast and make Hajj? Are there not people
Yes, of course. But this kind of wording
means that there is no mentionable merit
left for the Muslimin at that point.
Just a person may be clinically
alive, their heart is barely beating,
the rest of their body
might as well
you know, be dead because they're unable
to move, they're unable to stand,
they're unable to walk, they're unable
to function, and most importantly,
they're unable to
benefit others.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
[Arabic recitation]
after we
heat gold and silver in a kennel and
make it hot and all of the impurities
rise to the top, those impurities are
discarded and what remains as a benefit
to humanity, that is what Allah keeps on
the earth and keeps relevant. That gold,
that silver, that platinum, that
whatever it is.
And so our prophet tells us, "If the
people
of
corrupted, then there is no good in the
rest of you."
These two things put together
really help us to diagnose
the greater ummah today. When you look
around and you see all of the
all of the atrocities that are being
committed against the Muslimin, we say,
"Why? Why? Why?"
This is why.
Because there is a superficial
practice of Islam,
but on a deeper level, there's nothing
there.
There's ignorance. There's defiance.
There's disobedience. There's an attempt
to meddle with
the purity of Islam.
There is an attempt to innovate, an
attempt to worship other than Allah, an
attempt to add and subtract from the
from the message of Muhammad, sallallahu
alayhi wasallam. But then this is all
dressed with a veneer of wholesomeness
and righteousness and goodness.
A person may come into a hospital
and they have the most chiseled, perfect
looking body.
Just, you know, muscles and whatever is
the the picture of health.
But they have heart problems.
We don't look at when when someone walks
into the hospital to get check a
checkup, we don't look and say, "Well,
it looks good to me."
Looks all right. I mean, this guy
looks strong. We don't test his
strength.
We don't test his
mile speed. We don't test how much he
can bench. What do we do?
Check his pulse.
That's going to tell us if he's healthy
or not. We draw blood. That's going to
tell us if he's healthy or not.
It's not how the person looks.
And this is our pulse.
So, the Muslimin from that day on
were to always look at Ash-Sham and
notice what is happening there.
How strong is Islam in Ash-Sham?
What is going on with the people of
Ash-Sham? What is going on in Ash-Sham?
And that is going to be our pulse. So,
let us do that now.
Let's look at Ash-Sham.
Let's look at those countries now
that have been divided up into
countries. First of all, they've been
divided up and these borders have been
put up. Were they put up by the
Muslimin?
No.
Who who made these borders? Who made the
difference between a Syrian and a
Lebanese?
Who made the difference between a Syrian
and a Palestinian? Who made the
difference between a Palestinian and a
Jordanian?
Who made those differences?
Tell us. The English.
A hundred years ago, they said, "You're
Jordanian and here's your king.
You, you're Lebanese. Here's your king.
And you're Syrian. Here's your king and
your president.
And and you, you're Palestinian, but
even that now is trying to be taken away
from us. It's attempted to be taken away
from us.
And here's your president.
Right? And here's this group of people,
refugees. Oh, they were so oppressed by
Germany and the Third Reich and they
were so just take them in and let them
live. They're so peaceful. They're so
loving. Just you can all hold hands and
sing Kumbaya together. Right? And then
what happened? Now we're being burned
alive.
And those and our brothers and our
sisters have tasted nothing but iron and
fire
for the past
50, 60 years. And as far as Palestine is
concerned, anything after the '50s,
forget about it.
And so, the question is, what is the
pulse of the ummah today? We may look
at
Ash-Sham.
We may look at Ash-Sham,
Palestine,
Jordan,
Syria, Lebanon. We say, "Those people
should have been better."
But that's not what our prophet taught
us, is it?
He taught us that there's no good in the
rest of us
if we allow the people of Ash-Sham to
become corrupted. And if we allow
Ash-Sham to become corrupted. And if we
allow Ash-Sham to become infiltrated.
And if we allow Ash-Sham to become
colonized. And if we allow the young men
and women of Ash-Sham to be
to be
colonized psychologically
to the point that we are not even sure
where the road is anymore even if we
wanted to get back on the path.
This is how bad things have got. Now,
the question is,
how do we put this narration into
practice? Was this narration just for us
to be able to look at Ash-Sham and take
a general view on what the rest of the
Muslimin are doing? No.
He taught us
that the people of Ash-Sham, they
epitomize Islam
and they are the pulse of the rest of
us, the rest of the body.
If that pulse is weak and erratic, the
body is sick. We
all play a part in what happens to our
brothers and our sisters in Ash-Sham.
My disobedience all the way across the
water, all the way across the world, my
disobedience, my innovation, my lack of
knowledge about Islam, my
all of these things, they weaken that
body and everything goes back to the
heart and routes through the heart. If
the blood is infected at the very, very
tip of a person's toe, it will
eventually make its way back into the
heart. It's a reflection of all of us.
And so, we are all one ummah.
And that means that if any part of this
ummah
is out of line, it will affect the rest
and it will affect the deepest of our
organs. Any part.
In America, the Muslimin today in
America, which part are we of the body?
Maybe the toe? Maybe the tip of the
pinky?
Whatever we are,
we still affect our brothers and our
sisters there.
And a lot of times we want to make dua.
Sure. But raising our hands in dua,
those same two hands that we have used
to fill our homes with haram and to feed
our families with haram,
those same two hands that we have used
to toil and sweat in haram, to eat haram
and dress in haram and sleep in haram,
those two hands, when they raised to the
heavens, what effect will they have?
How does Allah look at those hands when
we raise them?
And so,
it's not just an issue of making dua.
The best thing a person can do for
his brothers, his sisters is
to begin to live the sunnah of Muhammad,
sallallahu alayhi wasallam. To love and
hate for the sake of Allah in the way
that Allah
loves and hates. To accept and to reject
based on the criterion of the Quran. To
learn the Quran, to recite the Quran, to
ponder its meanings, to embody its
teachings. This is what will work
towards fixing the issue. Anything else
is just what? Just band-aids.
Anything else is nothing but band-aids.
[Silence]
Yeah, that's accurate.
But here's the thing about Al-Mahdi,
right?
Other
religions and other factions,
other factions of Islam, they refer to
Al-Mahdi as what?
The awaited
Mahdi, right? Al-Mahdi al-Muntazar.
Correct? Even the Christians, the Jews,
they refer to the Messiah as the awaited
Messiah.
Not Ahl al-Sunnah. He's not the awaited
Messiah for us.
The reason for that, Al-Mahdi is not
going to come and save us.
Al-Mahdi is going to come when we have
figured this thing out and prepared that
body and he will come as the scholars
mention as a head for that healthy body.
Very different.
The Jews, the Christian
Al-Masih or the Messiah or the awaited
Mahdi is going to come to save them. For
us? No. The prophet teaches us he's not
coming to save us. He's coming to lead
us after we've already chosen salvation
over damnation. No.